your doctor may recommend a
hemorrhoidectomy to remove your
hemorrhoids if they do not respond to
more conservative treatment hemorrhoidal
veins are blood vessels within the walls
of the rectum and anal canal hemorrhoids
also known as piles occur when these
veins become swollen and the tissue
around them becomes inflamed a swollen
vein near the opening of the anal canal
is called an external hemorrhoid a
swollen vein within the rectum is called
an internal hemorrhoid internal
hemorrhoids are classified by how
advanced they are first degree internal
hemorrhoids are those that always remain
inside the rectum
second degree internal hemorrhoids will
extend outside the rectum during a bowel
movement and then return to the inside
of the rectum on their own third degree
internal hemorrhoids extend outside the
rectum during a bowel movement and then
must be pushed back inside the rectum
fourth-degree internal hemorrhoids
always remain outside the rectum and
cannot be pushed back in
before a hemorrhoidectomy you may be
given local or general anesthesia for
general anesthesia you will be given
medications to put you to sleep through
a breathing mask or through an IV line a
breathing tube will be inserted through
your mouth and into your windpipe to
help you breathe during the operation
your surgeon will begin by using a
scalpel electrocautery or laser to make
an incision in the tissue around the
hemorrhoid to expose the swollen vein
your surgeon may tie off the swollen
vein in order to keep it from bleeding
when it is removed your surgeon will
then remove the swollen vein and
inflamed tissue your wound may be left
open or your surgeon may suture it
closed finally your surgeon will place
medicated bandages over the wound to aid
in healing and protect from infection
the procedure generally takes about an
hour after your procedure your breathing
tube will be removed you will be
instructed to eat a high-fiber diet and
drink plenty of fluids to help prevent
constipation during your recovery which
usually lasts two weeks to two months
your doctor may recommend warm baths
medications and/or stool softeners to
make you more comfortable in the days
after your procedure most people are
able to return home the day of the
procedure but some will need to stay in
the hospital for one to two days
after you return home you should call
your doctor immediately if you
experience fever excessive pain drainage
from your wound redness or swelling